- Max, Tarek. Wie geht's?
- Hallo, Yanis! Uns geht es gut, danke.
Wie geht's euch?
- Sehr gut, danke.
Wir hätten gern zweimal
das Mittagsmenü mit Fisch.
- Sehr gerne. Setzt euch!
- Getränke wie immer?
- Wie immer, Tarek!
- Sind das deine Freunde?
- Ja, wir spielen oft
zusammen Fußball.
- Apropos, Max. Wann spielen wir mal
wieder zusammen Fußball?
Diese Woche?
- Nein, diese Woche kann ich nicht.
Aber nächste Woche geht's.
Am Freitag oder Samstag?
- Samstag kann ich nicht.
Da treffe ich Anna
nachmittags im Schwimmbad.
- Dann treffen wir uns am Freitag.
Geht das?
- Ja, das geht. Ah, ne, Moment!
Das geht doch nicht.
Robert kann am Freitag nicht.
– Ah!
- Dann sind wir nur sieben, oder? Max,
Julius, Linus, Daniel, Yanis, Lasse und ich.
Wir brauchen eine achte Person.
- Spielst du mit uns Fußball?
Hast du Lust?
- Fußball? Ja, wann?
- Wir treffen uns nächste Woche am
Freitag. Um wie viel Uhr, Max? Um eins?
- Das ist zu früh. Ich kann erst um zwei.
- Also nächste Woche Freitag um zwei Uhr!
- Und wo?
- Wir treffen uns hier im Restaurant.
- Okay! Ich spiele gerne Fußball!
- Super!
- Oh, Nico!
Entschuldigung, ich komme viel zu spät!